we're gonna get Kylie dead or live Jimmy
that just means like really big full
pouty lips and I feel like I have pretty
thin lips so I think it's gonna be a
pretty dress to chain I've never thought
about making my lips bigger I am
fascinated by Kylie Jenner's lips I want
them very badly my house I've been told
from some lovely people on Instagram are
very thin apparently yeah so she's kind
of saying like this is an alternative to
getting lip injections which seems like
a good idea I'm really intrigued to see
why I need all this stuff man okay she's
joined it like way up here I feel like
it's gonna touch my nose
oh god I still have a little mustache
this let's make like a weird butt out of
here
liner it's so off sensor oh okay I need
a pic so I could not imagine taking a
free ticket and then you kind of fill in
a little bit it was time for this I
don't know if I like this okay so now
we're gonna fill in everything oh and
you have to make sure it's matte you
can't use shiny lipstick because it'll
reveal your true lip line wait mine
looks so different from her like what if
you have to eat something or drink
something like what did you do then like
this is this attractive I am Brandis
things right now I am her this is it
Carrie so you get your concealer and you
put a little dollop on this like tiny
teeny angled brush I don't know I think
she said to use some foundation maybe to
make it pop a little more
oh my god wait this is literally the
last step this is like how it's supposed
to look
this looks Fang I mean the concealer is
like mixing with the pink and like it's
just an extra line it's hard to tell why
I was like let me see from afar
I think maybe if I had a proper skillset
I'd do it again maybe I can barely even
do a cat eye I mean like I already have
lipstick all over my face I don't feel
like I can walk out of here and be like
check me out guys like I'm totally me
right now I like me cuz I just wish I
was better at it I mean there's no way
you can kiss a guy or a girl or whoever
you want to kiss I like one on a date
with somebody you're like met somebody
new and I took off my makeup they'd be
like what the [ __ ] like you're totally
different just get plastic surgery had a
sheet post she's like it looks like
really concerned and like you put on
those like real Pony nails I have
beautiful lips and no parental
supervision